I've seen the whole series I really want
to say congrats you did such great work
thank you so listen I know you're
offered a lot of projects and I'm I know
a lot of scripts come across the desk at
least two at least two a year
um and so I'm just curious what was it
um
what was it about this one though
besides the fact that it's a fantastic
role what was it about this that um said
oh my God I need to do this well it shot
New York uh I was like one point for
this show and and I think I think I was
I I binge the scripts I went through
them very quickly I'm a solo reader in
fact I've been known to not read a
script and I went through them I read
them all and I thought these were
amazing and then I had a conversation
with Akiva and I thought it was nice
that I was playing somebody you know
very realistic woman in the 70s who's
who's trying to balance work and being
single mother and trying to be his
present with as she can with her kid and
but it's highly ambitious and trying not
to let the patriarchy bury her and and I
and I I just love the way she was
written I was very in awe of that and um
and I thought it was really impressive
that Tom Holland took this role because
it's definitely probably going to be the
hardest role he's ever played
and he's lucky
and and it shows lucky that he you know
brought it into fruition finally after
like 30 years of being of being the idea
of of this of this shows
um
you know it's it's real because of Apple
TV plus and like I just I felt like all
the all the pieces were in place for
something to be new for me like
something new and something different
sure um this show doesn't work without
you and Tom I mean you and Tom you know
are the show in terms of there's so many
scenes of you two talking
um Tom is clearly giving it as all so I
know it's a little generic but what was
it like doing those scenes with him when
he's clearly giving everything he has it
was fun because it's it
I didn't know exactly what he was gonna
do when he when when more would be
revealed I didn't know how he was going
to react I didn't know we had we had
done so much rehearsal in talking about
the process of the progression of these
two characters and how they've came to
trust each other and and and and and the
the gentleness with which Raya handles
Danny and and the warmth with which he
he he you know
um
melts into into this space it's really
profound it's a profound Bond and it
ends up saving both of them really that
connection but it was it was the and we
had fun between takes and then towards
the end of the show when things started
unraveling and twisting up a little bit
and and new people would
um emerge in the story it was so fun to
watch because I'm an actor who's I can
do only so much and then the other
person gets to
has to
Express what their character is supposed
to express and it's like it was it was
like
I don't know how to describe it it was
it was exciting it's not I've never been
through that before where I just didn't
know how someone was going to react and
it was at times unnerving like we're
making this really good show and he's
doing
he's doing
he's going there it was great yeah I
have I already have to stop I'm just
going to say yeah
I was gonna say every time I'm sorry no
I'm just gonna say the finale is
excellent It's really good you do you
think it brings it around
I I do and I um I really enjoy the
opening credits now after the finale
right exactly exactly Easter eggs in
those credits pay attention to the
credits exactly
um on that note I gotta go um congrats
for real good to see you have a
fantastic day thanks you too